it's gratifying to have maria bello join
the cast this year she's been a terrific
addition and people love the fact that
she loves being there and loves the job
and it means a lot when someone loves
their work and loves showing up in the
morning option one you tell me what's
going on
and none of it ever leaves the room
option two I find out on my own and I
will find out often times when you get a
character like yours in a character like
Maria's where they are you know this
intense energy that will often turn into
a romantic sort of energy on these shows
you see that a lot would you be cool
with that or do you think that's what
I'm cool with whatever they want to do
it really yeah yeah and then and she's
been really fun to tell mark opposite
and bat it back and forth with him and
she's brought something to the show that
we haven't had before which has been
invigorating to all of us yeah where it
goes from here I don't know you'd have
to ask a bunch of writers that but I'm
I'm game to play whatever they give us
how long do you want to be there for I
don't know if you thought about that we
all have contracts yeah aside from that
I've always thought that this show has a
creative footprint it's about the
writing room it's really that's what
drives this show it's about those people
who walk into that room and and still
come up with the ideas they do to
generate the character moments that all
of us get the opportunity to play and
currently that's that's as alive as it's
ever been and these shows all have a
path and whether they stick around for
three years or you know years right I've
done plenty of those and and because
we've all done some of those shows
that's why this one is to be appreciated
that's not the plan we had in mind
device that's plan that's the only plan
did you think that you know I'll get
this far did you think this would go how
much of your life did you think that
this would take out when you started
when you say you're gonna do it a TV
show I think actors think they all think
that the the pilot is gonna sell and and
maybe you'll be doing this for a while
sure I don't know that you put a time
limit on it obviously these things
aren't really designed to go three years
much less 15 right
there's been a lot of different forms of
this show from what it started as to
what it's developed into but I tell
young actors all the time on this show I
say look you know you you come to work
every day to work with friends there
they're terrific ly talented people in
all directions who only support you you
work with a great safety net underneath
you here at the show and oh yeah by the
way it's the number-one show in the
world
yeah so pressure it's not pressure it's
just about not forgetting what it took
to get there and what it takes to stay
yeah and and that's the part that that
maybe I'm most proud of being part of
there is that there's a lot of people
who make this show work and no one's
more important than anybody else and
that's the reason because we still
understand that that this that this goes
like it goes